yeah guys what's going on i'm feeling a
little silly
i've been in the house for a very very
very long time and i'm finally going to
be leaving and traveling to see my
family
for the first time in seven months i got
my coping test i'm negative and then i'm
going to take another test as soon as i
get home
this is all bringing me to the fact that
i want to vlog my trip there
and i just got this phone in the mail to
check out this is the xiaomi 10t pro
a huge thank you to xiaomi for
sponsoring this video yeah you got the
job
me
yeah i'm here for all of the remixes
the specs on this thing just sounds
absolutely crazy 108 megapixel ai camera
8k with optical image stabilization up
to 144 hertz adaptive sync true color
display
qualcomm snapdragon 865 a 5 000 milliamp
battery
with 33 fast watt charging and
5g let's open it up get packing and go
home because i
have to get on a flight very soon
very very soon and i'm not ready that's
one thing that hasn't changed
i was so excited to use my knife that i
just realized had a spring-loaded
uh deployment but i don't need it
[Applause]
this is the me attendee pro 5g
oh look at that we've just we've lifted
up the whole it's all here
look at that oh that is a that is like a
jet black
[Music]
um
all right oh look at that 5g5 g5 g5g all
right we need a sim card i'm gonna pop
one of those in
charge this up set it up and then we're
gonna get
on our way oh the typing feels nice
screen looks incredible
i mean i'm only at the wi-fi setup and
it still looks great
it has a nice feel to it usbc cable
you're for the wrong
country i won't hold it against you i
have adapters
what's in here
oh oh look at this i have a protective
case oh and a little dongle
that's a case what this really needs is
a cleaning cloth
oh my goodness i'm so smudgy i
definitely would prefer to not have a
case on it but i'm traveling and i would
like to keep this nice and protected
okay i'm gonna finish my setup start
packing
and take you guys along for i guess
what is going to be my first time
traveling in a very long time
[Music]
on our way to pick up jenna alex was
kind enough
to take us to the airport i didn't even
get a chance to film any of my packing
i've been up since like 5 a.m finished
the podcast
uploaded it packed and now we're on our
way
thank you so much for taking us of
course we were really
afraid of getting in an uber so
[Music]
this works out great yeah i'll give you
money
no don't give me money i'm gonna give
you money no don't give me i'm gonna
give you money
no just just give me five stars five
stars
maddie are you ready hi jenna what's
that yep
are you vlogging yes i am it's
oh my gosh we have so much stuff hi
daddy i think i'm more shocked about the
vlog
yeah i know jenna hi hi we're almost at
the airport this is the first time we've
traveled in
seven months seven months maddie hi also
seven months
wait no longer probably because he
didn't go to hawaii back
hurry back we have to let them know
probably on the holidays
yeah i'm
together we can reduce the spread of
germs and ensure
germs
[Music]
those two face coverings are not allowed
if you have either
please see customer service we'll
provide you with a paper mask
we'll make a general announcement for
the flight five minutes prior to the
boarding time
let's go buddy come on let's go potty
come on
go potty go potty
good boy
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so i just realized that i didn't
switch this
to shoot an 8k it was still shooting in
and we're at the airport now i'm trying
to figure out what to do with this hair
it's not happening but we are at a
layover we landed in denver so we're
here for like an hour
jenna and maddie sitting on the floor i
just switched everything
over to 4k whenever you get a new phone
you gotta always switch it to a higher
resolution this is ak content
show them this beautiful view we have
i meant the other way yeah but there's
people
everything's so weird
let's look at nice
the ground
we made it maddie is running
best buy express come on let's go
let's go there she goes
[Music]
hey jenna we made it home we did how
long did you sleep today
um i woke up pretty early but then i
took an hour and a half nap
yep am i in the frame push it this way
push it this way
a little less this way one more push it
this way there you go
hi we made it i
cannot believe what a long day it was i
honestly must say that
i really like the six foot roll and i
hope that we keep it forever
because i don't want to be close to
people but i won't be close to doggy
is maddie in the frame up a little
perfect
easy he's probably not focused
8k oh 8k doggy hey
hey hey hey
maddie he's a couple good dog